who taught you to hate yourself from the
top of your head to the soles of your
feet who taught you to hate your own car
who taught you to hate the rain
thank you belong to Malcolm X means
being black and proud in the society
that constantly reminds us that white
supremacy as the standard honesty
courage discipline grassroots and
seeking knowledge love for Humanity amen
a black man that we all need to pay
attention to
Malcolm means to me oneness welcome to
me really just reminded me that I am
valuable my life doesn't matter he's
good for justice for everyone he taught
me to be strong and be proud to be a
Muslim he represents perseverance and
perseverance in the face of all
unimaginable difficulty Malcolm to me
represents black liberation and
resistance he was able to rise up and
become one of the greatest leaders of
the 21st century they didn't teach us
about outcome they taught us about
Martin and Martin and Malcolm that two
sides of the same coin Malcolm X is just
as important as Martin Luther King was
in a time she wasn't respected for how
we believed but I personally believe he
was very conscious of this state that we
live in as black people living in
America I believe he was before it died
Malcolm in one word is love resilience
self determination warrior necessary
he's necessary Malcolm to me represents
a figure who very very long ago said
black lies man